[Musique]
tiens-toi jessica qu'est ce que tu veux
faire plus tard bedimo je veux être un
pompier et toi vincent beaucoup de temps
livre à moi impression d'être en
vacances même quoi je travaille
ouais d'accord et quel métier va te
permettre de faire ça plus tard
fonctionnaires comme vous monsieur
drapé du veau c'est gratuit
voici ton permis de chasse j'ai jeté
apporter des cayes décale mercier
fallait pas l'
les fonctionnaires seront encouragés au
départ en temps voulu
si vous refusez mon chèque gevo muté
dans un endroit pas rigolo du tout ils
veulent te virer il propose des
mutations dans les endroits impossibles
je vais y voit le signe
de blasphème pas vincent trémois postes
à pourvoir dans une fosse à purin et
vous il sanisettes ce que vous voulez
démerdez-vous mais trouver le mois
votre travail consiste à protéger les
chercheurs de la station contre les
attaques d'ours polaires
hi hi fi direct à l'entregent lors d'un
apéro chez des amis vous avez jamais
distingué mieux vendu flynn habite et je
vous rassure fabrice a été très bien
recousu non même un petit peu gras dès
le 10 à vous arrive
on va laisser refroidir un peu tôt on
signe un certificat de devenir nonne
habilitation de l'ue sur ceux avec qui
vous êtes supposés travailler là dessus
c'est un chercheur il sera quelqu'un
d'autre
[Musique]
j'apprends d'une mappemonde je vais la
faire tourner et puis je vais [ __ ] mon
doigt au hasard dessus et je lutte
pelletier à l'endroit du doigt
tiens bon vincent tient bon
[Musique]
la partie
en gros cette fois ci il ne fait pas
confiance blanc pas où ils sont égoïstes
impoli et arrogant c'est pas faux mais
c'est une toute petite partie des blancs
un cocon à peine de prison